jacob degrom and the mitch are on the
field 16 days since he started he's
missed two starts he's faced the rockies
as you all know in colorado struck out
14.
blackman makes contact and grounds went
down to mccann he handles that
flawlessly and it's a one two three
first thing on eight pitches for jacob
degrom
kyle freeland you know he's gonna be
amped up and there's always
[Music]
that level of emotion that you have to
control making his
2021 debut here on may 25th the 1-0 on
the way swing on a ground ball left side
base hit going into left field for vr
jonathan takes a big turn around first
runners going and that is
a strikeout at the plate
but a double steal
on the bases
so two in scoring position with one out
for james mccann now he's 2-2 on mccann
and he grounds one to short that'll get
a run home story's play will be the
first as vr comes in with the first run
of the game
rbi ground out from the cannon that's
one nothing new york
so the double steal
produces a run
here's the one two
got him
right down the middle and that'll end
the first ink there was a hit a walk and
on a fielder's choice a run for the mets
[Music]
o2 to krone swung out and missed strike
three a hard slider down and away and
degrom has his first strikeout one man
away ryan mcmahon coming up
this ball's hit a long way to center
field and it is gone
tie ball game ryan mcmahon 13th of the
year he got on that heater and he drove
it out to left center
what a gorgeous swing he's fourth in the
national league at homers and the
rockies have tied the game one to one he
could adjust to the left of the 370 mark
[Applause]
and nunez takes strength three called
100 miles an hour on the inside corner
to get him a couple of strikeouts in the
air for degrom but the home run by
mcmahon ties the game
strike three
that is the third strike at all of a
backward k's as peraza
has a discussion with chad fairchild
and he beat him with a fastball four
strikeouts first time through
and toppy is down on three pitches so
two two-thirds of the way to an
immaculate inning degramas fanned the
first two in the third
great pitch
he struck him out on a fastball down and
in here come the blue birds cascading
down on lindeur
1-0 pitch vr's running pitch ticket for
a strike throw to third and it is not in
time a stolen base again for jonathan
villarreal mike redmond's hoping he gets
good news from
brian jones
let's see if he comes off mcmahon
believes he comes off the oven mitt
hits the bag he keeps the tag on
he may have he's about to be out
see uh
he is out what a break
so it'll go as a caught stealing
2-5
and this is bounced easily to mcmahon
and that'll end the threat
three men left aboard
and he struck him out with a fastball
foul tip held by neato five strikeouts
now for degrom second time he's gotten
chrome
struck him out got him with a changeup
degrom with six strikeouts on the night
he's not retired eight in a row
lined
just over the head of crone a base hit
for de grom he's going to try for two
the throw by blackman not in time
did he bounce off again
rocky's uh
challenge on on
we don't we don't see the feet there
this angle should give us an idea
no double for you it'll be a single for
degrom end of inning
that's gonna be an assist as well for
blackman
strike three call got him with a
fastball in the outside corner and
that's seven of them tonight for jade
2-2 to joe
struck him out
three in a row for degrom nine for the
night halfway through tied at one
[Music]
[Applause]
there goes vr it's a pitch out nunez's
throw right on the money and vr is
tagged out
how often do you pitch out in today's
game rockies called it right
and vr caught stealing
for the second time in this game
all right eamon meanwhile here jacob
degrom's return to action is done after
five innings and 63 pitches five innings
he gave up three hits in a run no walks
nine strikeouts
pulled over the back that's a fair ball
vr with the one hop already got him oh
wow
jonathan bjorn turning in a gem
that club's broken
what a play and had to really work it
quickly to get a fast man in trevor
story
and now tomas nito came up with the
bases loaded in the third
and needle
out to deep left center field topia back
in the gap and it's out of here
the ball came back in but i'm almost
certain that ball went out
it's close gare whether it hit the
orange line i'm fairly certain it hit
the blue panel above the orange line and
it should be a two run homer for neato
and the mets dugout is indicating that
and i'm certain that the umpires will
get together and take a look at it but
neither appears to have hit a two-run
homer that would give the mets a
three-to-one lead if not
he got dom smith home with a run to make
it two to one
definitely hit the blue
eminem's sign and it will be a two-run
homer for neato
and now they call it a home run so there
you go they did it on their own very
nice i like that neato's third home run
of the year a two-run shot to make it
three to one new york oh my nicely done
[Applause]
oh he's switching oh he's mid stream
that's outstanding he's pretty good look
at that if you can catch a bat you can
certainly go whoa that's pretty good now
he's now he's really turning it on
that's not what he said
smith and infield hit he's at third
peraza single
mabin just walked
and he struck him out on a slider
so no damage done
we'll go to the ninth the rockies
trailing three to one
3-2 coming to mcmahon
struck him out
he stayed committed to the slider and
now they're a two-man down i think that
was just an excellent job by nedo
he struck him out and the ball game is
over
edwin diaz stays perfect and save
opportunities he fans three in the ninth
jacob degrom makes a successful return
to the mound tomas nida with the big
home run and the mets even up the series
as they snap a three-game losing streak